[Music]
dale is in pueblo colorado dale welcome
to the ramsay show
thanks for taking my call guys sure how
can we help you got a couple questions
for ken here real quick
i recently had a bad horseback riding
accident i lost both my legs
oh dale i'm so sorry
sorry
that's okay
dale how long ago was that about two
years oh man
i'm so sorry
so i'm trying to find a career yeah i
can go to
yeah
dale what were you doing uh
for work prior to the accident
managing people
you were leading leading
leading a team of people
farming home industry yeah
okay
okay and have you been on uh physical
disability are you on disability right
now
just recently
just recently got there
yeah okay
um the reason i'm asking this is i want
to see what our maybe our moves are here
uh what kind of financial shape are you
in
bad
wow
dude what kind of what kind of debt do
you have
what is it well i i don't have already
any debt i don't have jet it's not a
problem it's just my life can barely
afford to live okay what are your
disability payments right now what are
you getting in on a monthly basis 1300
okay 1300 are you living by yourself
living with someone what's what's your
question
with my fiance's constant little problem
okay all right
um
if the fiance was not in the picture
uh in your area of colorado what would
rent cost you oh about 900 a month okay
so there's hardly any margin there at
all
so we definitely need to get income
um
are you making america the 1300s
i'm sorry
i can't make an additional 1300 a month
on top of my disability and i have to
suffer any loss of insurance or okay
anything like that all right so with the
injury being two years ago are you uh
able to function in and out of society
just our in our wheelchair what are you
what are you what's your i walk i walk
every day oh you do
i still walk every day i farm every day
i
still have horses and
i still ride horses okay now wait a
second three times a week okay so so
obviously this is a traumatic injury but
physically you are not limited now
i am limited to weight picking up but
i'm limited to i can't pick up over 40
pounds i understand that but if i heard
you correctly you said that you used to
lead people you were in a management
position prior to the accident
yes well dale
while i am grieving for you and this is
incredibly traumatic and i understand
your emotion what's keeping you from
getting back if you're riding horses and
walking all over the place and being
physically like of what's keeping you
from getting back into the workforce and
leading people again you lost your legs
you did not lose the ability to lead
well i think there's a lot of things
going on that it's uh i know
society doesn't look at disabilities the
way they used to i understand
and by the way dale i'm not minimizing
that what i'm trying to get you to
identify is what's really holding you
back
well the kidney failure he'll hold me
back to you i'm on dialysis now three
days a week
okay all right so there okay i was not
aware of that i didn't catch that so
yeah so you're limited um into how much
time you can work because of the
dialysis
yeah i can rearrange that a little bit
if i need to rearrange the evenings or
weekends or whatever i'm not opposed to
that um dale have you been seeing all
right here's the deal we only got about
a minute and i don't want to rush this
but here's the thing i think there's two
things you've got to do and i think you
need to be doing them consecutively
um if you've already seen counseling you
need to continue to to get some
counseling for the grief and the trauma
you've got some relationship issues
going on with the fiance you have got to
get healthy emotionally and you got to
get with a professional if you've not
done counseling you've got to do that
simultaneously i want you to try to work
your dialysis schedule out to where you
can work more hours and i want you to
get back in it there are a lot of people
who'd love to give you a second chance
because you're a hero you've overcome an
unbelievable devastating injury and you
haven't forgot how to lead people and
i'm going to suggest to you dale listen
that you loving on people and leading
people
will do wonders for you getting healthy
again you need greater income
to get that spine straighter again and
believe in yourself that you can in fact
recover you can in fact do this